it's been a real interesting atmosphere
it's not excitement and this lot feels a
bit about division and stuff so yeah
it's really kind of interesting
atmosphere really this seems to be half
the place seemed to be not really sure
how it's gonna go well half the people
have seemed quite excited and quite
excited by the atmospherics dancing I
very much enjoyed my first experience of
a laser party congress it's been
exciting enthusiastic and everything
I've helped you know this is the best
conference of ever have I've ever been
to I was in Manchester
in 2010 those are all the bad but you
know writing was this come to these
conferences this side made of copper to
me it's just been really positive this
year you know we're moving in a
different direction we've got you know
we're talking about some of the things
that we wanted to talk about on the
doorstep campaigning in the last
election a lot of people talking about
austerity about housing about struggling
to make ends meet and we're starting to
talk about those things found it's
fantastic but I've come more for the
social side of things than the political
side of things so I probably the karaoke
was my favorite Christmas movie bar it's
a sort of wait and see i think but so
far i think people have felt pleasantly
surprised blues who had low expectations
for those who had high expectations
think they felt they'd be met fair found
it really good it's been a very
different atmosphere from previous years
seems to be a lot of more hyper activity
between members and supporters which is
really good it's been invigorating the
the people here is really exciting puffy
employers are things people feel that we
really have got a chance to make a
difference we're hearing a different
types of politics actually more
reminiscent of what the people are
saying on the streets as well I've
enjoyed it I mean I think it's been a
real productive conference where the
party has been unified I'm ready to play
the fight to the toys over the next five
years very exciting something that I
hadn't expected is the overall
enthusiasm remembers when you come into
it you're with a group of obviously
like-minded people and everybody very
excited I don't know how much that's the
Corbin factor or it's something to do
with every neighbor conference I have a
feeling it's a bit to do with jeremy
corbyn because a lot of the conversation
revolves around him i spected a bit
divisive of us a bit at one heart it's
been very genial a lot by the compass
emotions at work out of us about fender
what a genial pleasant experience or
things it's been one of the most
inspirational I've ever been I've ever
witnessed I've been to one before which
was okay I think this could be a really
historic moment fantastic it's my first
conference and it's a really exciting
sort of exercising democracy great
debate I've really enjoyed it